a proposito di andate e ritorni io sono
appena arrivata da trondheim che è una
città in norvegia per andare
parlare di trauma può sembrare un po
spaventoso può sembrare un po strano se
non fosse appunto che faccio la
psicologa e dal 2015 quindi da più o
meno quattro anni lo faccio con una
veste nuova che è quella veste che mi ha
permesso di andare sempre più verso sud
con il cappottino dell'operatore
umanitario ma perché sono partita cosa
che mi ha fatto partire forse era
appunto la ricerca della mia valigia su
misura
forse oggi non se n'è parlato tanto di
valigia ma la valigia in realtà una
parte fondamentale di un viaggio di
solito dopo aver prenotato il biglietto
prima di partire si prepara la propria
valigia
partirei dal 2015 più o meno da quando
mi sono auto diagnosticata una malattia
terribile che non troverete su nessun
manuale diagnostico ed era la
insoddisfazione da divano io non ne
potevo più di stare seduta sul mio
divano a guardare le cose che
succedevano intorno a me e mi faceva
male esseri ferma immobile andare avanti
con la mia vita tutto sommato comoda e
vedere quello che succedeva impotente
allora ho deciso di trovare un rimedio è
l'unico rimedio che ho trovato è stato
il partire il fare l'agire le cose non
credo che capitano in realtà per caso
comunque un sabato pomeriggio in agosto
nel 2015 era appunto sul mio divano in
quanto sofferente di insoddisfazione da
divano e stavo cercando su internet
qualcosa che mi potesse aiutare a
superare questa questa insoddisfazione e
casualmente o meno mi si è aperta la
pagina di un'organizzazione umanitaria
che in quel momento stava proprio
cercando uno psicologo
che potesse andare in sicilia lavorare
con le persone migranti ho risposto alla
l'applicazione ho fatto il percorso di
selezione e sono partita viaggio verso
la sicilia un viaggio si verso sud ma è
un viaggio relativamente breve
dopo la sicilia sono scesa ancora un
pochettino e sono nati in burundi che
nella mia testa forse non so neanche
bene dove forse no quando si dice va in
bronzo forse in tanti non sappiamo
neanche dove sia allora un giorno un mio
collega una volta in missione ha provato
a spiegarmi un pochettino la magia del
suo paese e ha provato a spiegarmi dove
fosse questo o questo suo paese e ha
fatto questo disegno e burundi
effettivamente è molto più piccoli in
proporzione nella realtà però alla forma
del cuore
e come dice lui è posizionato
esattamente nel cuore dell'africa
ecco io in quel momento in quel piccolo
paese
mi sono innamorata e ho capito che il
mio lavoro sono a mio percorso verso il
trovare la mia valigia fatta su misura
forse forse era già un buon punto cosa
succede però che a volte le valigie si
fanno e si fanno male io nella mia prima
valigia
ero partita con innanzitutto una valida
un trolley gigante che già abbastanza
scomodo pieno di cose abbiamo messo i
vestiti le creme saponi ma soprattutto
avevo messo tantissimi libri promessi
manuali diagnostici avevo messo tutti
quei testi che negli anni di lavoro qui
a piacenza ma avevano supportato nella
mia attività mi ero completamente
sbagliata io fino al 2015 lavorava
piacenza aveva lo studio in centro da
casa lo studio ci mettevo tre minuti in
bicicletta e da dire tanto 5 a piedi ed
era l'ideale sceglievo io ancora riavere
i pazienti molto comodo senza fatiche
organizzative ma ho deciso di appunto di
partire con una con una valigia un po
più scomoda quindi
la mia prima valigia più o meno era così
libri libri libri i libri i libri perché
nella mia testa c'era l'idea che tutto
quello che avevo imparato fosse
universalmente applicabile che le
diagnosi che per anni avevo studiato e
applicato andassero bene ovunque
quindi io non avevo fatto altro che
impacchettare questo studio nella mia
prima valigia e mi ero tremendamente
sbagliata
successivamente ho capito che tutti
questi testi non erano poi così
essenziali non era così essenziale
portarsi tutta questa conoscenza e tutto
questo modo di pensare di vedere alle
cose ad ogni spostamento ad ogni
missione quindi le mie valigie
successive sono cambiate e dal valigione
con libri libri libri sono arrivato ad
avere un valigi no magari un po più
grande di questo però con dentro
palloncini bolle di sapone colori
festoni oggetti e quelli sono stati la
svolta nella mia professione intra in
quanto per attore umanitario
come si impara a fare la valigia si
impara con l'esperienza una volta una
parte si porta mille cose si rende conto
che non tutte servono allora poi la
modifichi togli mettere essenziale
rasmus i un pochettino
quindi io ho cambiato la valigia ho
cambiato il posto e ho cambiato anche lo
studio che è diventato più o meno questo
queste cose le ho imparate con
l'esperienza
allora vorrei magari raccontarvi qualche
cosa di questa mia esperienza e vorrei
partire da una paziente che è venuta
mentre stavo lavorando in congo nel
nostro ospedale
una bambina che aveva 9 anni e era
venuta rappresentata nostro ospedale
accompagnata dalla nonna e dalla
sorellina di sette questa bambina viveva
in una città una cittadina molto lontana
rispetto a quella in cui eravamo noi con
il nostro ospedale
i suoi genitori erano morti entrambi a
causa del conflitto che c'era in cui in
quei giorni nel kasai è una regione del
congo la bambina viene accompagnata
dalla nonna perché dopo la morte dei
genitori un amico del papa ha preso le
due bambine per accompagnarle dalla
nonna a piedi per tanti tanti chilometri
e tanti tanti giorni e quotidianamente
ogni singolo giorno
questo personaggio ha violentato la
bambina di fronte alla sorella una bimba
di 9 anni
voi immaginatevi come si potesse sentire
questa bambina
credo sia molto difficile in realtà da
immaginare
e provate ad aggiungere a questa idea
che forse vi siete fatti come si possa
essere sentita trova entrando in
ospedale e trovandosi davanti una strada
persona bianca che non parlava una
parola di ci ruba che la lingua che si
parla ii vestita in jeans e maglietta
allora sicuramente per lei non è stato
facile neanche questo ok allora la
nostra il nostro sforzo la nostra come
dire l'efficacia di quello che abbiamo
fatto con questa bambina è stato proprio
quello di accettare che ci fossero
queste differenze di accettare che ci
fossero questi oscar ostacoli dettati
anche dal fatto che non parlavano la
stessa lingua e non avevamo le stesse
abitudini
la svolta nella nostra relazione
terapeutica e anche nel percorso è
avvenuta grazie a un pane che il tessuto
tipico buttato per terra e alle bolle di
sapone
io sono andata avanti giorni e giorni e
giorni a fare con questa bambina delle
bolle di sapone
allora a noi possono dire poco o niente
ma approvate e vi chiedo davvero di
farlo
provate un secondo a chiudere gli occhi
a dimenticarmi di sapere cosa sono le
bolle di sapone e pensate che voi
soffiate dentro un buchino si formano
delle palline trasparenti che volano
queste palline cambiano colore con la
luce se nei tocchi si rompono ma non
fanno rumore si bagnano solo un pochino
è qualcosa di magico qualcosa di
meraviglioso e per me queste bolle di
sapone sono state una magia perché sono
state la cosa che ha permesso di
arrivare con calma e con i tempi della
bambina a un risultato enorme
io se penso a questa bambina
ci pensa col sorriso per un semplice
motivo che siamo riusciti attraverso le
bolle di sapone a farle sperimentare che
cosa volesse essere cosa volesse dire
essere bambina a fare sperimentare
qualcosa che per i bimbi e naturale no
lo stupore incredulità capite che
bisogna un pochettino rivedersi no
quando quando ci si sposa quando si
fanno le valigie vorrei ritornare
indietro un passettino con le foto vi ho
fatto vedere il mio studio di piacenza
di fatto vedere un ipotetico studio di
ramin kong però potrebbe essere ovunque
questo per dire che la flessibilità e la
fantasia sono qualcosa che non possono
mancare sono qualcosa che ci devono
accompagnare quotidianamente perché sono
l'unica cosa che ci permettono di
alleggerire le nostre valigie che spesso
sono troppo pesanti sono cariche di
oggetti spesso inutili oggetti
inadeguati pensate alle volte in cui
siete partiti con i maglioni pesanti e
poi magari c'erano 35 gradi quindi
l'importanza è veramente quella di
imparare ad alleggerire togliere invece
di mettere e non si tratta solo di
oggetti dovete considerare che ci sono
certi paesi all'estero ma anche in
italia in cui ad esempio la medicina
tradizionale e la magia hanno un ruolo
fondamentale
uno può crederci non crederci può essere
critico non critico ma importante
saperlo perché nei momenti in cui ci
portiamo a confrontarci con chi a queste
cose ci credo dobbiamo esserne
consapevoli
vi faccio un esempio rispetto a questo
in burundi si è presentato un giorno un
paziente che aveva tentato il suicidio
questa era un uomo un lavoratore un
padre di famiglia con un'enorme
responsabilità sociale che è quella che
hanno molti uomini in molti contesti
cioè quella di non potersi permettere la
fragilità le necessità
il dolore quindi parlando con la
famiglia era emerso che questa persona
si era buttata da un tetto perché gli
era stato detto
in forma di ordine da una creatura che
era appunto metà animale e metà persona
per me essere poteva essere anche facile
forse entrare a gamba tesa dire guardate
non è così
probabilmente signora depresso e può
essere una conseguenza di questa sua
patologia non sarà sicuramente stato la
creatura mezzo uomo mezza mezzo animale
a dirgli di farlo grazie al cielo non
abbiamo fatto così
grazie al cielo abbiamo ancora una volta
alleggerito il nostro bagaglio e abbiamo
fatto lo stesso lavoro che io ho fatto
lo stesso lavoro che avrei fatto a
piacenza semplicemente l'ho fatto senza
dare un nome alle cose troppo spesso noi
siamo vedere inquadrati nel voler dar
nome le cose volere dalla precisione e
questo non ci permette di ricreare delle
mappe ricreare dei significati e questa
cosa è una ricchezza fondamentale
dall'africa ho imparato in realtà da
casa riguardando l'africa che troppo
spesso si pensa all'africa come a un
posto grande così
cioè tutti gli africani arrivano da un
buchino di un metro per un metro
sono tutti uguali perché ovviamente non
siamo capaci di riconoscerli no quindi
per noi sono tutti uguali
parlano la stessa lingua hanno gli
stessi miti hanno le stesse culture le
stesse conoscenze in realtà non è così
partire con una valigia vuota o comunque
partire con una valigia piena ma sapendo
che possiamo lasciare qualcosa la per
poterla riempire di qualcosa di nuovo è
quello che ci permette di scoprire che
l'africa non è quel metro per un metro
ma come immagino queste abbiate un
continente e anche piuttosto grande è un
continente dentro al quale si parlano
2000 lingue ci sono tante religioni ci
sono tante credenze è un continente che
è principalmente abitato dalle persone
di colore ma non questo non per questo
tutte le persone di colore sono africane
e qui vi faccio un auto apertura che
tecnicamente è significa dire qualcosa
di personale per aprire un discorso
quasi siamo io e mio marito
la mano di mio marito ha chiaramente una
mano di una persona di colore
se io ci penso credo di non aver mai
incontrato nessuno che non abbia chiesto
o che non abbia pensato chissà da quale
parte dell'africa tuo marito arriva mio
marito arriva da haiti nel mare dei
caraibi
d'altra parte però vedete noi ci
portiamo avanti queste queste valigie
questi questi vincoli no che ci fanno
vedere solo quello che noi ci vogliamo
aspettare
come vi dicevo e l'africa grande
l'africa è piena di persone di colore
piena di corso di persone bianche
l'africa è un posto estremamente
variegato come le persone di colore
possono essere più scure meno sicure
sono pieni di sfaccettature di sfumature
si abbronzano non tutti mangiano
piccante non tutti ballano bene ci sono
delle capitali in africa che per fascino
modernità storia non hanno nulla da
invidiare alle nostre
ci sono dei villaggi in cui non c'è
internet non c'è la luce ma nel 95 per
cento dei villaggi dei posti in cui si
va si trova una maglietta del barcellona
questo per cercare di spiegarvi come le
persone che ne incontriamo possono
essere diverse anche se noi cerchiamo
sempre di dare delle categorie come io
sono diverso da una persona di parma di
cremona di moore onia o un finlandese
può essere diverso da uno spagnolo
così succede anche per quelli che noi
chiamiamo spesso gli altri sempre
cercando di dare una macro categoria
l'ultima cosa che vorrei condividere con
voi è una cosa che mi manca tantissimo
quando sono fuori della missione in
africa
i bambini hanno paura spesso dei bianchi
come noi cresciamo col mito terrificante
dell'uomo nero loro crescono col mito
terrificante dell'uomo bianco quindi a
me manca una volta scoperta questa cosa
mi manca tantissimo quando insomma
quando sono qui a piacenza che mi muovo
per le strade vedere queste ore di
bambini che ti guardano stupiti
c'è qualcuno che terrorizzato piangendo
scappa e invece c'è qualcuno che curioso
ti corre incontro e che urla di queste
voci ne che orano musungu musungu
musungu che ha l'uomo bianco
quindi io l'invito che faccio è quando
voi partite quando noi partiamo di
mettere sempre nella valigia gli stessi
occhi che hanno i bimbi quando orano
musungu musungu grazie